denise يحمّل الطعام في سيارته من أجل
التسليم ، تم التبرع بالإمدادات التي تم فرزها من قبل المتطوعين في
هذا المستودع القديم من
جميع أنحاء أوكرانيا وفي الخارج كان دينيس
موسيقيًا قبل الحرب في
أقصى الشرق تحت سيطرة الحكومة الأوكرانية
وتحت قصف مستمر من
القوات الروسية بالقرب
من الإمدادات.  والمتطوعون
الآخرون هم ما يبقي هذه المدينة على قيد الحياة ، حيث
سقط صاروخان خارج
مبنى شقة ناديا المتهالك الذي يعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية ،
وهو ضغط العيش تحت هذا القصف
أكثر مما تستطيع
تحمله.  خائفة ، أريد أن أكون هادئًا وسكينة
مرة أخرى
مع احتشاد القوات الروسية في الشرق
لن يكون هناك هدوء
ولن يكون هناك هدوء
جالس على سرير المستشفى
تروي جوليانا الليلة التي أصيب فيها منزلها
كنت في المطبخ وبدأت تقول
منزلها الآن في حالة خراب.
ترقد أكثر من 20 جثة مبعثرة في
مشرحة المستشفى
ملفوفة في ملاءات وبطانيات في انتظار
دفنها
على مشارف ج.  المزيد
من الأدلة على أن الحرب قد اتخذت
هذه المقبرة التي تم حفرها على عجل
والتي بدأت منذ بدء الحرب ،
انظر فقط إلى تواريخ 7 أبريل ،
9 أبريل ،
3 أبريل ، 4 أبريل ، وتستمر وتطول ،
وستستمر القبور  سرعان ما تملأ